[Applause]
oh oh my gosh so okay I'm very excited
for you personally because I remember
the first time we zoomed you were
actually at your house in Hawaii I think
and I was like why do I not live where
you live
um and then also there was Art in the
background we had this whole
conversation about how you love painting
and I had no idea about this background
of yours and now this is your first like
ever right like solo like art exhibition
this is it you're so crazy good man May
13th thank you Kelly yeah this one tries
to be at least it's an unexpected
surprise so many dreams I know that's
the name of it right right yeah that is
one of my favorites I love I love this
storytelling behind it too because I
watched this whole video about you
describing like that's right where your
roots and like you know and why you
paint and the stories behind them it's
really beautiful yeah I just you know
I've been an enthusiastic painter All My
Life as a friend of mine says and uh
this is my first exhibition I've had
this body of work it's a retrospective
yeah starting in 1987 really uh and I I
dropped into La in 1982 I came here I
got a job I got lucky Remington steel
yeah and I stayed and you know I could
afford paints and brushes even though
I'd never painted but I loved drawing I
bought all this art supplies and they
all went into a cupboard I heard you say
this in your video and I was like that's
so everyone though right it's like you
you work hard to make the money to be
able to afford the things you love and
you want to do but then you don't have
the time because you're working so hard
exactly yeah that stinks because it goes
in the closet how long was it in the
closet until you pulled it back out it
was uh it was there until 87 and my wife
Cassie God bless her she got sick with
ovarian cancer and and then one dark
night was just this kind of head and a
Heart full of pain and fear I just got
all these paints on I started painting
and those paintings start the show and
there's some kind of articulation I
think and some progression of the work
and they've all been in storage and I
thought I have to let them go I mean if
not now when otherwise they're just
going to sit there it's such a cool way
to share with everybody to connect with
everybody because yeah I forgot that I
used to draw I just forgot and then and
then I literally found myself doing
something that I had to kind of pay
attention to and I was having a hard
time and then all of a sudden I've
doodled this whole thing by the end of
the yes this thing and I was like I
forgot I even Drew but I was doing it as
like almost a therapeutic way do you do
it a lot for them this is definitely a
therapy yeah it kind of because I heard
your wife Gardens my darling Keely she
Gardens yes and you paint I love this
therapy yeah so and we have this little
Homestead out there in Kauai so that's
the heartbeat of our life really I think
we live in a time which which has been
very the thump of anxiety in our lives
in these days is constant and I follow a
lot of artists on Instagram and so many
people now are whether they're weaving
or the Lino cutting or painting you know
it's it's necessary to to have art in
your life I think 100 I would not have
made it the last three years without
being able to write music like that's my
outlet right and I actually heard that
you wanted to do album covers was like a
big thing for you whenever you started
well yes I mean I left school at 16 with
nothing but a cardboard folder of
drawings and uh paintings that was that
was my qualification I got a job in
Putney South London and it was 69 so the
music the world of Carlos Santana those
great albums covers and that was my
dream to make album covers yeah it
didn't happen but my son who's a
musician he asked me to do his album
cover so I know I was going to bring
that up how full Circle and also such a
beautiful thing for you to do with your
kids yeah thank you like I have kids and
I can only imagine like my kid would ask
me to be a part of something you know
because sometimes we're not cool
yeah it takes a long time to be cool and
then uncool at the same time yeah but
anyway uh yeah that's it what a great
time for that that happened it is so a
lot of these uh a lot of these paintings
come from a certain kind of therapeutic
anxiety nourishment of the soul and uh I
love it and it's important that's that's
that's where you begin with you love the
the song the poem that you've written it
starts in your heart the painting that
you make
and then you give it away absolutely
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
guys I'm going
thank you
[Music]